right where she left off Jump's got
eight of the 18 for the
Cardinal Watkins will try to answer
retaliation is a
must yeah whether it's the athletes
themselves or former athletes you
bringing it up to speed you're seeing
consumers really understand their piece
of this by buying a ticket by buying
people aren't coming to one game and
then not coming back right they're
coming to one game they're investing and
then they want to find more and more to
consume just the buzz here around able
to get it over yeah take advantage of
the mismatch Watkins from the free throw
line Juju Watkins woke up this morning
and said I'll choose buckets in
three Hardy now guarding
Watkins Watkins stops pops in and out
and back in again murmurs here inside of
Maple's Pavilion Watkins pull up three
get out of town Juju
Watkins they witnessed the Ju Watkins
show for the majority of this
night Watkins tries a 3C silences the
[Applause]
crowd 50 a 50 piece for
Watkins for ju guu
Watkins and with that she sets the USC
record for most points in a game on the
Trojan
team 16 points what a night what an
upset and what an important victory for
USC